hey guys so today we will be doing
something a little bit different since
the new Star Wars movie will be out in
cinemas real soon we are going to
showcase to you the 15 largest
spaceships from the Star Wars universe
these spaceships are among the largest
in fiction and out sized many of their
competing franchise ships such as those
of Star Trek with the common imperial
star destroyer dwarfing the enterprise
by a mile or so
so in this list we are going to focus on
many of the capsules ships seen in Star
Wars not just movies by the animated
flicks and even graphic novels and
comics
so in essence anything cannon in Star
Wars we are also going to include the
death stars on the list since they are
ships or to be more exact weaponized
stations and others which are comparable
and even bigger than them but apologies
beforehand since we won't be including
the star killer base as it is not a ship
or a station but a modified icy planet
that was made into a super weapon we
won't be including the husk station as
well as it was built around a moon and
is simply a planetary mega structure and
not a mobile ship so now that we have
that off the table let us start by
putting something common in front for
reference an imperial star destroyer
which is by far the most common and most
recognizable ship in this universe this
ship is one mile in length or 1.6
kilometers in comparison the Rebel
Alliance Mon Calamari Cruiser is a bit
smaller at 1.2 kilometers so let's get
into the list at number 15 comes the
manager for Class C CH dreadnought with
a total length of a bit more than 7.6
kilometers or 4.75 miles
also known as a manager for class
warship and the first-order dreadnought
it was a model of siege dreadnought used
by the first order during their conflict
with the resistance it had a crew of
53,000 officers a hundred and forty
thousand enlisted personnel and 22,000
stormtroopers the manager for class was
armed with two orbital autocannons that
could fire a salvo of two rounds each in
quick
session before recharge was needed the
starships dorsal surface featured
26-point defense laser cannons for
protection against our fighters and six
tractor beam projectors were located on
a ship's bow next at number 14 we have
the praetor mark 2 battle cruiser which
has a length of 8 kilometers as the
highest estimate also known as the
praetor to class Star battle cruiser it
was a warship class that served the
Imperial Navy it was a model in a Star
Destroyer design family marked by
characteristic wedge shape considered
the largest battle cruiser design known
the predator possessed a dagger shape
similar to other prominent warships in
Imperial Navy the praetor mark - battle
cruiser possessed at least 90 weapon
systems including various spherical
turrets on the dorsal ventral and trench
areas of the ship in addition it also
possessed hull armor and deflector
shields now at number thirteen comes the
monitor do class warship which was a
powerful vessel while star destroyers
like the venator class could stand up to
a handful of separatist resistant glass
light destroyers a star dreadnought like
the matter tattoo could withstand an
assault of up to a thousand of these
warships as such the vessel carried
reactor equipment large enough to force
the length of its hull up to its length
of eight kilometers so having cut its
ties with the techno Union prior to the
Clone Wars the kuat drive yas began
building starships for the republic
years only among its new designs were
the magnitude 2 class an upgrade of the
pre-war manner to class dreadnought we
should form the part of the kuat sectors
defenses in peacetime
these heavy vessels form a part of the
Supreme Chancellor Palpatine snoo
centralized Republic Navy during the
Clone Wars so coming in at number 12 is
the monitor 3 class dreadnought which is
another manager but a class 3 another
class 2 and class 4 which is previously
mentioned it was a very large
dreadnought scale warship in the
Imperial Navy as well as the third class
of start dreadnought developed under the
monitor series alongside the bell attack
last dreadnought which was smaller than
the tree manager class warships
the monitor tree was specifically
designed to be a hulking weapons
platform and was a bit longer and more
heavily armed than its predecessors and
it's contemporary cousin at 12,000
meters in length or 12 kilometers it was
essentially a scaled up version of the
monitors several of these participated
in the events leading up to the Imperial
Civil War number 11 sovereign super
stardestroyer this was a super
stardestroyer produced by the Galactic
Empire at the behest of the Galactic
Emperor Palpatine who envisioned a fleet
of 15,000 meter long vessels the
sovereign class hosted a crew of six
hundred and 1670 with 4075 Gunners and
required a skeleton crew of at least
86,000 during development it was
estimated to require crew of 600,000 a
sovereign class super stardestroyer
carried five years worth of consumables
and could carry a hundred and thirty
thousand troops like the larger Eclipse
class super stardestroyer the sovereign
class featured an axial super laser on
par with a Death Star the axial super
laser was also the reason why the ship's
helm was designed to be 15 kilometers
load for the minimum space required to
house these generators at number 10 the
Asura
class star dreadnought this was also a
15 kilometers long ship and had a hull
shape similar to the executor class star
dreadnought being primarily shaped like
an arrowhead it was considered the
second largest of the standard starred
retinal line with only the executor
class being larger as well as the
largest in the Imperial Navy in a family
that included the monitor class ships
the class was equipped with a large
amount of gun batteries martyred along
the ridge of the ship as well as the
flat dorsal and ventral surfaces many of
the batteries were positioned in
patterned clusters its armaments of
turbolasers
while weak in comparison to the executor
class star dreadnaughts was nonetheless
powerful enough to nearly vaporize a
planet number 9 the Eclipse class
dreadnought also known as the Eclipse
class Super Star Destroyer it was a
class of Imperial super star destroyers
factored by the kuat drive yachts and
mainly used around six years after the
Battle of Endor like the sovereign class
they were regarded as a new generation
of superstar destroyers
although technically dwarfed in length
by both the executor class star
dreadnought and a vengeance class
trainer by 1.5 kilometers the Eclipse
class at 17.5 kilometers long or 11
miles nonetheless exceeded even they
executed class in terms of overall mass
and volume its size was large enough for
it to be classified as a Space Station
coming in at number 8 is the executor
class star dreadnoughts
also known as the super class Star
Destroyers they were some of the largest
and most powerful Imperial starships
ever created along with other classes of
massive Imperials capital ships they
were also referred to as super star
destroyers although they were
technically classified as star
dreadnoughts the most distinguished
super star destroyer was the executor
the flagship of the Dark Lord of the
Sith Darth Vader it measured at 19
kilometers in length and utilizes 13
engine thrusters and were outfitted with
a class 1 hyperdrive a titanium
reinforced hull over 5000 turbo lasers
and ion cannon batteries and concussion
missile tubes number 7 the Vengeance
class dreadnought this was based on the
standard Super Star Destroyer design the
executors class as such the ship class
was approximately 19 kilometres long in
addition because of its dimensions the
ship class sometimes possessed the
standard classification of of space
station in contrast with the executor
class the Vengeance class frame was
supplied with a slender built more
narrower nana star star destroyers
almost like a sword in comparison to the
usual daggers shape the Vengeance class
height contrasted its length which was a
little more than 150 meters and with
downward sloping armor dominating most
of the dorsal frame the next and number
six is the eye of Palpatine and this was
a colossal asteroid shaped Super's
dreadnought constructed at the behest of
Emperor Palpatine during the second year
of the galactic empire it was destroyed
12 years
Battle of Yavin and more than 90
kilometers long this deadly warship was
the Emperor's first super weapon it was
referred to as both a dreadnought and a
battle moon as part of a secretive
origin the vessel was made to look
similar to an asteroid the reason for
this was officially stated as the means
of protection from detection by enemy
vessels and world's number 5 the mega
class star dreadnought also known as the
mega class Star Destroyer this was a
class of star dreadknot utilized by the
first order during their conflict with
the resistance with a length of 13.2
kilometers but a width of more than 60
kilometers it was large enough to drop
eight resurgent class Star Destroyers
six externally and two internally it
crewed over two million - and 25,000
personnel the only operating ship of its
class was the supremacy disparagingly
nicknamed snoke's
Bora self as a flagship the supreme
leader snoke and the mobile headquarters
of the first order it was split into two
by the resistent flagship raiders while
attempting to destroy the remnants of
the resistance fleet near the planet
Cray number four the Yuuzhan Vong chorus
drona also known as world ships in the
galactic basic standard they were
immensely large organically created
vessels that house entire communities of
the Yuuzhan Vong providing them with
food and shelter they also serve a
staging ground for long battles similar
in function to the reborn Emperor
Palpatine eclipsed class destroyers a
world ship was a transport a battleship
and a psychological weapon in all in one
it is unknown if these figures were
systemic for all worships but the Banu
wrasse one of the largest world ships
was a hundred and twenty kilometers
across almost the size of the first
Death Star at number three it's none
other than the original Death Star also
officially named as the ds1 orbital
battle station or the ultimate weapon in
early development stages and later
referred to as Death Star one it was a
moon sized deep-space mobile battle
station constructed by the Galactic
Empire
the station was ferrite and made
160 kilometers or 100 miles in diameter
with 357 internal levels a large concave
dish in a northern hemisphere made up
the super laser emitter the station's
command rate she was located in the
northern hemisphere above the dish of
the station super laser you know it's
big when it has hemispheres instead of
parts so for the number two spot is yet
another dead star
also known as dead star mark 2 or ds2 or
simply the second Death Star it was a
partially completed moon sized battle
station constructed by the Galactic
Empire asked the successor to the first
one it was larger and more powerful than
the first one
like the first Death Star that start to
long terms purpose was to terrorize
planets and star systems in league with
the Rebel Alliance through the use of
its planet destroying superlaser upon
completion the Death Star 2 would have
an immense battle station size of 200
kilometers in diameter that featured 560
internal levels which could house 2.4
million passengers and crew and at the
number one spot comes to Centerpoint
station known to the killings as the
cholera law or the world polar it was an
ancient Space Station that was capable
of moving entire planets with as tractor
beams it was created by the third hive a
hundred thousand years before the Battle
of Yavin with a width of a hundred
kilometers and a length of 350
kilometers it was larger than both the
two dead stars from a distance it
appeared as a huge partially translucent
sphere with two small cylindrical poles
Centerpoint station contained within its
colossal bulk an extremely large
intricate collection of ultra
high-energy systems a true relic of a
bygone age and with this we come to the
end of the video so do like share and
subscribe for more videos do click on a
notification bell for regular and actual
notifications and for the new viewers do
check out our channel as we have tons of
other videos on monsters and creatures